i don't know why my kids block me on
their stories
because i still see them on my other
work instagram accounts
candace cameron beret's kids may have
blocked their famous mom on instagram
but she has a fin stuff for that you
know
a fake instagram account i'm not missing
out
on sunday the mom of three posted this
video to her insta feed
revealing that her kiddos 22 year old
natasha
21 year old lev and 19 year old maxim
have blocked their mom on social media
so she can't see their instagram stories
i don't know why my kids block me on
their stories
because i still see them on my other
work instagram accounts thanks for
blocking mom
yeah candace is no fool she has multiple
instagram accounts to work around
all that thanks for blocking mom and
while the 45 year old actress's kids may
not want their mom to see what they are
posting on social media
they do still enjoy some quality family
time
there's nothing like my family on sunday
candace hit up her own
insta story to reveal that her fam has
some seriously similar taste when it
comes to movie night
so we're having family night making
dinner this hilarious thing
just happened guys
it actually was so cute so we're trying
to
decide what we're gonna watch tonight
and um
we each had we were putting it on a
piece of paper
that we we got two choices each and then
someone's gonna pick it out of the bowl
and here
here are the movies that we chose
not knowing what the other person chose
yeah so all of them picked pink panther
our favorite family movie
is the pink panther all four of us
wrote pink panther on there and then
val wrote moana lev wrote the
incredibles
and natasha and i both wrote we all like
children's movies
and candace she was loving it
[Laughter]
i love this movie candace cheers natasha
lev and maxim with her hubby of 25 years
valerie beret and when etie caught up
with the fuller house star
in may she dished on what makes their
marriage work
some days you just gotta hang in there
cause you're just you're in it
and you gotta stay in it even though you
don't want to be in it
it's hills and valleys along the way but
uh
man i especially with last year
all of us staying home so much it was
like oh we're spending so much time i
remember
all the things that i forgot about
because life has been so busy so
if there's a silver lining to what to
2020
it's that i really enjoyed my husband
and my family
you